[Applause]
such a sharp rebuttal to the notion of a
world without poverty it's called eat
burlap man any more bids the hammer
is up so for 1.5 million dollars to the
gentleman who is clearly with a
prostitute our next item is a bold
daring work about nature in the female
form let's hear more about it from the
performance artist herself Hilde thank
you for being here thank you for having
me how's it hanging
you were hanging okay
Hilde or Hilde I prefer Hilde you prefer
Hilde yeah and you're from Norway yes
huh hey redheads up there in Norway yeah
okay what were you doing in the tree I
was making an art film
it was a sequel yeah what was the
original project called
silent movie
silent movie yeah in complete contrast
to this one who came to help you Adam or
Sarah neither of them
Sarah was up on a mountain Adam thought
I sounded like a seagull so he did hear
you yes he did
how long were you up there cuz the video
cuts out like what ten minutes the whole
thing was 30 minutes about and the
camera ran out of battery just couldn't
take it anymore offed itself I get a
little anxious watching it it's a little
panic inducing it's good to know that
you're human now if you had to do it all
over again would you start screaming
help earlier no I would never do it
again maybe you need to work on your
enunciation help sounded a lot like hell
I'm trying to project as much as
possible so a pronunciation is not on
the top of my list I think that was the
problem I think so many people heard
help and they were like oh that person
doesn't need help they need help which I
don't know what that is
was there a lesson learned always hide a
like knife in your butt crack oh well
that seemed like horrible advice who
came with her rescue you Genta Gita yeah
I need AG inta in my life oh yeah how
did she get you down by averting her
eyes she was so ashamed of your body
well it's kind of difficult when your
vagina's head height oh yeah I mean
listen it was as bad of a position as
you can be for for a vagina was this
your first time nude on camera no what
I'd like to hear what other works were
you just if someone were to one to look
that up no okay no what kind of not was
that a noose not it was a noose who
knows how to tie a noose I don't know
someone who would like a slight morbid
curiosity
hey now if you were to ever off yourself
do you have any idea how you would do it
I would have some sort of elaborate gas
chamber oh I don't like that you had
that answer ready
we're your parents disappointed when you
told them you wanted to be an artist no
they're very supportive that's not good
you shouldn't have supportive parent
does not create a good artist what's
your least favorite type of art nope
nope don't have an answer to that
there's nothing that upsets you like oh
I can't I can't handle this no cuz then
it would be good okay no right uh you
were really are an artist are you
familiar with the work of Shia LaBeouf
yes
snap leg snap leg snap leg snap leg snap
leg is that performance art yeah I would
say so
he's a crock of did this ruin
bondage for you how do you feel about
people describing your work as heart
pinata part snuff film well damn that
makes me sound cute doesn't it well I
don't know it seems tragic and I've
heard a thing called porn and I should
be ashamed to be a woman oh really oh
yeah I got death threats from who I
don't know some closeted conservative
perv what happened to that tree oh I've
got some here for you you know after
what it did to me I thought I'd return
the favor so you murdered a tree yes is
this the only piece you have no I have
other pieces that are made into boxes to
contain the USB stick that hold the film
huh what about coasters yeah no you
should make coasters which was worse the
ropeburn on your ankle or the sunburn on
your lady part there's no Sun in Norway
hey it seems like a beautiful day it was
surprisingly for Easter oh really that's
what you did on Easter Sunday I don't
I'm not Christian listen I know you're
not Christian I saw you hanging upside
down naked I'm afraid that Jesus was
Christian what did he do he did hang to
a tree
correct one time but he didn't want to
be there enough chitchat Hildy pop that
robe off and show us hang woman
society's dirty affair with inversion
that's not what it's called i hain't
spruced it up
Wow we'll start the bidding at three
easy payments of two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars do I hear 70 70 70 70
thank you very much sir 750
[Music]
boom I like what I see
hey get is great girl can't be happy
what me today and I wasn't gonna be
losing one made 1 million
oh don't be just a child up front play
with a ball let me get one one five and
put 5 1.5 1.5 1.5 1.5 1.5 boom 1/4 I
thank you everybody
we seem to have a power outage everybody
please stake home sorry about that going
once old
[Applause]
[Music]
you